NARRATOR: From Marvel films,
to television, to parks,
to comics, we have
everything coming
to Marvel in 2020 so far.
That's right.
You're watching
Earth's Mightiest Show,
and we are telling you
everything coming in 2020
to Marvel that we
know of so far.
Yes.
LORRAINE CINK: Who knows.
From films to TV
to games to comics.
We've got it all.
All right.
You guys, how about we kick
it off with Marvel Studios.
Oh, yes sir.
I think we shall,
because first up
is Marvel Studios' Black Widow.
Natasha has her very
own solo film directed
by the amazing Cate Shortland.
An incredible cast is
being added in addition
to Scarlett Johansson.
And have you guys
seen the trailer yet?
I'm talking tons of spy action.
I'm talking a certain
character that Langston likes.
LANGSTON BELTON: Taskmaster.
There it is.
I cannot wait to see
Marvel Studios' Black
Widow in theaters on May 1st.
LANGSTON BELTON: Also coming
up from Marvel Studios, Marvel
Studios' The Falcon
and the Winter Soldier,
the first Marvel
Studios original series
to hit the new streaming
service, Disney Plus.
We're going to have showrunner
Malcolm Spellman bring us
these characters after
the events of Marvel
Studios' Avengers Endgame.
And of course we have
Sam Wilson and Bucky
Barnes attorney, Anthony
Mackie and Sebastian Stan.
But check this out.
Wyatt Russell joining
the cast as John Walker.
Oh, it's going to be amazing.
And you got to check
out Marvel Studios' The
Falcon and the Winter Soldier
when it debuts on Disney
Plus in the fall of 2020.
There's even
more action coming
from Marvel Studios
to the box office,
namely Marvel
Studios' The Eternals.
Very cool.
Directed by Chloe Zhao.
That's going to have
an epic all-star cast.
I cannot wait to
see that trailer.
We've seen some of
the art already.
It's going to be really cool.
Make sure you stay tuned.
So much more to come.
Get ready for Marvel Studios'
The Eternals in theaters
November 6th, 2020.
Yeah.
And if you have
Disney Plus already
or you don't, go
subscribe, because you
can see Marvel's Hero Project.
It's on right now.
And it's going to be
continuing through 2020.
This show is so inspiring.
It's all about these heroic kids
that are making a difference
in their communities.
And Marvel honors them in
really awesome different ways,
one of which is a comic book
that features them as the hero
of their own story, which
you can actually read those
at marvel.com/heroproject.
They're super inspiring.
And in this world
of all worlds, still
we deserve just to feel great.
It's a delight.
How about this?
Marvel's Storyboards is going
to be a 12-episode nonfiction
original series following
Joe Quesada, Marvel
Entertainment's
executive vice president
and creative director.
He's going to be joined by
some special guests talking
about the origins of
their Marvel fandom
and their storytelling
process and how
they bring stories to life.
And that's coming
to Disney Plus.
Yeah.
But we've got more here
yet for Marvel television
this year, including the final
season of Marvel's Agents
of S.H.I.E.L.D. All of our
favorite agents are returning,
we saw in a new
trailer from D23.
And baby, there's time travel.
So sign me up.
I can't wait to see what
they do with this season.
It's going to be awesome.
And it will return to
ABC in, of course, 2020.
OK.
Ryan, Lorraine.
Do you like Spider-Man?
- I do.
- Yes
- Do you like animated series?
Yes.
Well, Marvel Animation
has you covered.
Marvel's Spider-Man animated
series is coming with season 3,
and it is entitled Marvel
Spider-Man Maximum Venom.
And some of your
favorite characters
are going to be
getting venomized.
And that's going to be
very exciting to see how
animation takes on the
tendrils and tongue
and eyes and teeth of Venom.
So I'm very very
excited for that.
And you can check
that out on Disney
XD in April of this year.
All right.
You guys, we've talked
about animation,
we've talked about theatrical
stuff, TV, nonfiction,
fiction, all that good stuff.
Let's talk about Marvel games.
We can't talk about Marvel
games without starting
with Marvel's Avengers.
Big game everybody's
excited for.
That is releasing this year.
It's so cool.
You've got Black Widow,
Iron Man, Thor, Hulk,
Captain America, Ms. Marvel.
LORRAINE CINK: Yeah.
Kamala Khan, baby.
RYAN PENGAOS: Yeah.
It's really cool.
You're going to have
a single player story.
There's going to be a
multiplayer component,
so we can all play together.
It'll factor into
everything that's going on.
It's coming so soon.
May 15th, 2020.
It's going to release
on Playstation,
Xbox, Google Stadia, NPC.
Preorder for early beta access.
Bam.
Actually then Kabam.
You guys know the awesome
game Marvel Contest
of Champions created by Kabam.
But now we're looking forward
to Marvel Realm of Champions.
It's going to be a new game.
It's a real-time action RPG
where players are transported
to Battleworld, where all
heck is breaking loose,
and you have to align with
a house to sort of survive.
So you have all these
cool different houses
that you can align with,
from the House of Iron.
You can see who that
might be aligned with.
Spider Guild, Patriot Garrison,
Pyramid X, and more to come.
And your battles all contribute
ultimately to your house's
battle world domination.
And you can get the game on
the App Store and Google Play
this year.
You'll notice that some
of the things we love
about video games, that they
let us step inside our favorite
Marvel characters' skins
and armors, if you will,
because Marvel's Iron
Man VR is coming to us,
and you get to play as Iron Man.
You're going to come
face to face with Tony
Stark's iconic allies.
You're going to go blow for
blow with villains like Ghost.
You are shooting
repulsor blasts.
You have Friday giving
you intel in your ear.
It's incredible.
And you not only save
Stark Industries,
and the world of course.
You are seeing
Tony Stark himself.
Oooo.
Mysteries and secrets abound.
So you got to check out Marvel's
Iron Man VR, releasing February
28th, 2020 on Playstation VR.
Now, I'm going to
play that at home.
And what if I wanted to
experience some really cool
Marvel things outside my house.
Where would I go for that?
Instead of virtual reality,
you want to experience reality?
Boring.
RYAN PENGAOS: Yes.
Well, have I got
a thing for you.
Disney Parks and
Resorts has lots
more stuff coming up this year,
happening all over the world
even.
First off, let's
kick off big Avengers
Campus is slated to
open in 2020 at Disney
California Adventure Park.
I'm so excited for this.
There's going to be a
ton of cool attractions
and different things
to experience,
like you can take a ride
in a web slinger vehicle
and hang out with my friend
and yours, Spider-Man.
You can also have a big fun
or maybe just a little fun
at the Pym Test Kitchen.
There's going to be a new
Avengers headquarters.
And of course, you can
have rogue encounters
where you get to meet all
your favorite Super Heroes.
Like I ran into Captain
America, and I said, hail Hydra.
And then it didn't
go well for me.
So I wouldn't recommend that.
Don't do that.
Mm-mm.
But you guys can look out
for Avengers Campus coming
to Disney California Adventure
Park in, you guessed it,
this year.
- Yes.
So now let's say you want to
travel a little bit farther.
We are in New York now.
You can go to Paris to check
out Disney's Hotel New York
and see the art of Marvel,
and this new swanky hotel
promises it's going
to have a modern art
gallery assembling some of
Earth's mightiest artwork.
This opens in summer of
2020 at Disneyland Paris,
but you can start making
your bookings right now.
So, you're going to make
your bookings right now,
but you also need to start
reading some new comics,
and there's so many
new comics this year.
We've got Spider-Woman.
We've got Strange Academy.
We've got Guardians of the
Galaxy, Savage Avengers, Falcon
and the Winter Soldier, Ant-Man,
Gwen Stacy, Nebula, and phew,
phew so much more.
That was all in one breath.
That was fantastic.
Yeah.
Right.
How about I tell you a little
bit about my friend, Thor.
Oh!
RYAN PENGAOS: The
Thor new series
written by Donny Cates, art
by Nic Klein and Matt Wilson.
The last year has been really
tough for our pal, the Odinson.
He's gone through a lot,
the War of the Realms.
Now there's a
little bit of peace.
But the Black Winter is coming.
Duh, duh, duh.
Whoa.
Sick.
Not good for him.
But maybe fun for us.
Yeah.
I'm also very much looking
forward to Iron Man 2020.
If you guys have been
reading Tony Stark Iron Man
you know that title is awesome.
Written by Dan Slott.
But now Iron Man
2020 is going to have
Dan Slott and Christos Gage
working with artist Pete Woods.
Trouble's been brewing.
They're talking about a fight
for artificial intelligence
rights.
And now a new Iron Man is
stepping up, and hot take,
he's not super nice.
Ohhh.
I don't know who
you're talking about.
That's a pun if you know
what we're talking about.
And we're gearing up for it.
Oh, boy.
Now, picture if you will,
the world of Marvel Comics
is a giant bucket.
What we've told you about,
just a few drops in the bucket.
More comics will be coming
from Marvel in 2020.
We'll be announcing them
throughout the year.
Of course, stay tuned for all
that from all of our shows
that we do.
We're going to tell
you all about them.
We get excited.
And if you missed
any comics, of course
there's Marvel Unlimited.
You can go check it out
at marvel.com/unlimited.
You can go to your
local comic shop.
Get yourself some comics.
This has been the
show, all the stuff
that's coming to
Marvel in 2020 that we
can tell you about so far.
You're welcome.
Yes.
But of course, keep your eyes
on marvel.com for more cool
stuff coming throughout 2020.
What are you guys most
looking forward to happening
in 2020 from us here at Marvel?
Is it kittens?
Is it puppies?
Yes.
Is it movies?
Is it comic books?
Is it friendship?
Is it anime ship?
You tell us.
At #earthsmightiestshow.
So many choices.
You guys, this is Marvel--
Your Universe.
So many choices.
[MUSIC PLAYING]